if you run YouTube for uh how long
should you run it for a year uh how
would you change it how would you
improve it that's hard because you know
obviously I'm biased because we're doing
really well but I feel like when I open
up YouTube on my television I get the
videos I want to watch I don't I don't
know I don't I don't ever open it and
wonder like what are these what are
these 10 videos on my home page when I
click on a video messages I don't ever
wonder what these are like I I and maybe
it's because I'm very adamant about like
the kind of videos I watch and I try not
to watch videos that I don't want to get
recommended more because I just that's
how I think but I'm very happy with how
it is at the moment I think one thing
though that I just hate with the passion
is the comment section on YouTube it's
just so bad
um but that I know that's not something
that's gonna 10x the growth of the
platform but if you think about it you
go to Reddit to read comments and
somehow like that you know usually the
top 20 posts uh on a popular Reddit post
are not spam you know what I mean like
have you ever clicked on something on
the front page of Reddit and then most
upvoted reply to it is like go check out
my site right here and it's like trying
to scam you out of a thousand dollars
yeah yeah I can't even think of one
instance I've ever had that happen so
like Reddit it's so nice to click on
post and just see what people have to
say and I almost wish like you had that
same feeling when you read the comments
on a YouTube video instead it's like
it's so many people just copy and
pasting so many Bots that just grab the
top comment for your previous video and
paste it over so top comments on every
videos are the same and the things that
break through that are just scammers
trying to get you to give them a
thousand dollars for a free uh you know
fake ad that comment section is one of
the most Lively on the internet so be
amazing if YouTube invested in creating
a natural Community like where people
could do high effort comments and be
rewarded for it like on Reddit yeah like
actually right out along that would make
me so happy because like when I upload a
video I usually go to Twitter to see
feedback like I read my comments and
I'll flip through newest but it's just I
feel like to read it and Twitter just
give me so much better filtered feedback
especially now that with Twitter blue
because people pay eight dollars a month
um any I've noticed like any tweets I
get from verified users now they're
usually not just garbage troll takes
like these are people paying eight
dollars a month like they're usually
relatively sensible and so it's been
pretty nice like after I upload video I
just go on the verified tab on Twitter
and just see what people have to say and
yeah anyways I live for the day that
YouTube's like that